Let's go next to Abby from Idaho, Abby from
Idaho, you're on the air.
Hello, yes, you're on.
Hi, how are you?
How are you doing?
Well, thank you.
So I actually live in Washington State right
now.
I'm in the Navy, so I'm stationed out there.
But I was I was born in Idaho.
Oh, OK.
Well, yeah, but we birthplace residents.
It's all fine.
Yeah.
I was just curious what because I was talking
to some of the guys I work with which most
military band members are actually kind of
libertarian, more than I'd say Republican.
Right.
But I was asking them if they would accept
court decisions on these voter fraud cases.
Right.
And I wonder what you think the Trump supporters
are going to do.
You know, in the courts, obviously come back
and say there's not any voter fraud that they're
going to accept.
If these state delegates decide to go for
Trump, they're going to be, you know, on that
bandwagon if you're talking about faithless
electors, right?
Yeah.
Do you think that they're going to be on the
electoral bandwagon or do you think that they're
going to accept the election?
I mean, so they're kind of two different questions.
The first question is, if Joe Biden eventually
if courts say they didn't find any voter fraud,
there are going to be some.
Trump is to say the courts are biased and
there are some Trump as to who might accept
it.
OK, if you end up having a situation where
there are faithless electors, my guess is
a libertarian would say, hey, the the electors
are allowed to go the opposite way of their
state if they believe that it is important
to do so.
So my guess is that the libertarian leaning
folks you're talking about would be fine with
it.
I don't expect that to happen.
I think that, you know, we've had faithless
electors in the past, but they've never reversed
the results.
And with such a margin for Joe Biden, you're
not going to get 20 or even 36 potentially.
Depending how Georgia goes, you're not going
to get that number.
Yeah, and that's that's kind of what we talk
about at work, and I also feel really bad
for some of these guys because they are Republicans,
but not necessarily Trump supporters.
And they have a you know, at least like a
can have thoughtful political discussion.
And I feel like these Trump supporters are
kind of bringing down their ability to have
like a reasonable discussion right now where
you're saying you feel bad for anti Trump
Republicans.
Yeah, I kind of do, because I do think that
having difference to the political discourse
is important.
I'm a progressive and I wish that everybody
would be for Medicare for all and and all
the things I want.
But I realize it's not a reality, you know.
Yeah, that's fair.
I mean, I think, you know, let's let's keep
everything in context.
I feel worse for the families and victims
of coronavirus than I do for anti Trump Republicans
who might be struggling to have conversations
right now.
But the point is still well, I understand
what you're saying, that the pro Trump people,
they just want to shut everybody down, anti
Trump, Republicans, Democrats, progressives,
everybody.
Yeah.
And I just want to think, you know, I know
all of your listeners, at least the progressive
ones, are definitely abiding by social distancing
and mask Maheswaran.
And you may not realize this, but the the
military is taking this very seriously.
I am aware of it.
Yeah.
And for instance, like I got in contact with
the guy at work who is covered positive for
like maybe all of five minutes.
And because of that I was stuck home for two
weeks.
You know, I did a huge contact tracing at
work, which is how everybody should be doing
it, really.
But because of that, me and my sailors that
work for me, we really can't even go home
for the holidays.
Right.
So it really sucks to see these Republicans
out there just freaking out about how much
they love the military, but they refuse to
wear a mask.
It hurts, you know, because they're the reason
why I can't go home.
Absolutely.
My mom, absolutely.
Everybody who wants you have people who want
to open everything and yet they don't want
to wear masks.
It's like, wait, hold on a second.
If everybody wore masks, we'd be doing much
better.
Much more could be open.
Yeah, well, thanks for talking to Veterans
Day.
All right, Abbi from Idaho, currently in Washington
State, thank you so much.
Excellent.
Excellent to hear from you.